bonjour bienvenue à tous parlement hebdo
bonjour moracchini journée qu'elle
bonjour à tous 45 minutes pour
développer l'actualité politique et
parlementaire et l'actualité cette
semaine est très chargé les mois après
le viol et le meurtre d'agnès cette
collégienne de haute loire
à peine le choc et l'émotion passée le
gouvernement annonce en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi sur
l'exécution des peines
comprenant de nouvelles mesures contre
la récidive eva joly sème la zizanie
attaques au vitriol contre le candidat
socialiste françois hollande démission
de son porte parole
la candidate des verts pourra-t-elle
tenir le doute est permis même dans son
propre camp au sénat la partie recettes
du projet de loi de finances 2012 a été
votée mais totalement modifié par la
majorité de gauche
dans le même temps jean pierre bel le
président du sénat annonce une série de
mesures il veut à sénart économe et plus
transparents et avec nos peaux commenter
l'actualité de la semaine chantal
jouanno bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau
alors vous êtes maintenant sénatrice ump
de paris arrivée à la haute assemblée
avec les élections de septembre vous
avez alors quitter votre portefeuille du
ministère des sports de ministre des
sports ça fait environ maintenant deux
mois donc que vous siégez au sénat c'est
un choix vous ne regrettez pas un pas du
tout dans la soirée mandat de
parlementaire donc c'est mon premier
mandat de parlementaire exactement après
avoir été conseillère régionale aussi à
paris non je regrette pas du tout c'est
déjà c'était un engagement de c'était
vis-à-vis de paris aussi c'est un
engagement se consacrer à paris donc je
pense qu'il faut pas trahir sénat de
gauche
alors c'est compliqué j'ai pas connu la
précédente situation en tant que
sénateur donc je peux pas comparer je
n'ai pas comparé j'aurais préféré que le
sénat reste à droite bien évidemment ça
aurait été bien moins compliquée pour le
pour le gouvernement et puis surtout on
se trouve là dans une avec un sénat
extrêmes entre guillemets politisé et
c'est inévitable dans l'émission mais
laisse effectivement assez différent de
ce qu'on vous avait raconté les autres
sénateurs par exemple c'est très
différent parce que moi j'ai connu sénat
en tant que ministre danse des du
travail de fond avec des conciliations
possible avec des compromis possibles
trans partis souvent d'ailleurs parfois
sur le dos du gouvernement
donc quand un ministre mais mais mais
sur un travail de fond extrêmement dur
c'est à dire que pour un ministre ce
n'était pas facile c'est beaucoup plus
difficile c'était beaucoup plus
difficile d'argumenter au sénat parce
qu'on n'était pas dans des clivages
politiques on n'était pas les sénateurs
de droite ne suivaient pas toujours loin
de là la ligne du parti avait une
recherche de consensus qui n'est plus
aujourd'hui c'est toi qui n'est plus du
tout non non non non là on est sur un
clivage très très fort et voilà c'est
pas la pression vous avez l'impression
de faire partie de l'opposition l'a en
quelque sorte on fait partie de
l'opposition dans le scénar oui c'est
évident c'est évident avec un évidement
un positionnement très compliqué vous
n'avez pas de marge
vraiment vis à vis du gouvernement c'est
évident mais vous fait vraiment partie
de l'opposition ici d'ailleurs on voit
même dans l'organisation des débats on
voit dans les prises de paroles climat
qui avait totalement changé pour vous
alors vous êtes sans doute mieux à même
que moi mais ce que vous êtes des
observateurs vous êtes bien même que
moins de le dire mais je pense que c'est
un climat qui n'est pas du tout ce n'est
que vous avez connus qui se rapproche
beaucoup de l'assemblée nationale on va
parler d'eux reste de l'actualité lundi
l'actualité est marquée par la
mobilisation du gouvernement après la
mort d'agnès
interrogations et stupéfaction après le
meurtre de la collégienne nouvelle
polémique sur des failles éventuelles
dans la chaîne pénale
face à l'émoi et la polémique le
gouvernement annonce une série de
mesures sur l'évaluation de la
dangerosité des mineurs un sujet signé
yoan heure-là sur le perron de matignon
ce soir trois ministres côte à côte
claude guéant luc chatel et michel
mercier venu annoncer de nouvelles
mesures anti récidive en matière de
crimes sexuels
pearson qui publie le fort un crime
sexuel particulièrement grâce peut être
placé en centre éducatif fermé lorsqu'il
est mineur deuxième un point il faut
partager l'information entre les
services et ressorte que la justice
l'intérieur l'éducation nationale la
santé communiquent entre eux pour
s'informer sur le fait qu'il ya un
criminel commis particulièrement grave
et qui est située dans telle ou telle
précision du premier ministre désormais
les chefs d'établissements scolaires ne
pourront plus ignorer le contenu du
casier judiciaire de leurs futurs élèves
pour le gouvernement pas question de
donner l'impression de m'être sur l'
ouvrage une nouvelle loi d'émotion pour
les proches du candidat socialiste
françois hollande
la réponse n'est plus un problème de
textes les dernières lois votées ne sont
pas tout et vous inefficace certaines le
sont la plupart n'ont pas reçu les
moyens d'être appliquée sur le plan
budgétaire donc voter des lois ça peut
être utile ça peut être nécessaire même
parfois même dans ce domaine et même si
beaucoup ont déjà été votées le problème
que c'est que la plupart du temps ces
lois ne sont pas applicables faute de
moyens ce soir les parents d'agnès ont
fait savoir qu'ils s'opposeraient à
toute politisation du meurtre de leur
fille qui vient pourtant une nouvelle
fois de remettre la question de la
récidive au coeur de la bataille
présidentielle
qu'est ce que vous répondez à notamment
à l'opposition qui dit que l'on répond à
l'émotion par la loi encore une fois
d'abord je voudrais juste dire que c'est
c'est ignoble ce qui se passe le crible
et le crime et ignoble on est encore
dans une période de deuil pour la
famille et pour les proches
donc c'est enfin moi j'ai une pensée
pour eux quand ils voient ce ce
déballage et c'est d'abord je pensais
vraiment le crime est ignoble c'est ce
que je personne ne peut imaginer pour
ses propres enfants
et c'est vrai que là la polémique
politique
immédiatement après les faits elle
rajoute de l'ignominie à l'ignoble donc
voilà je trouve que c'est tout ça est
assez indécent et concernant la loi est
ce qu'il fallait absolument encore une
fois légiférer sur la loi on est bien
évidemment qui a toujours des problèmes
d'application qu'il faut toujours adopté
adapté par dont les textes mes textes à
la réalité il ya eu toute cette
polémique avec les responsables de
l'établissement qui ont dit on ne savait
pas que cet élève effectivement avait un
tel un tel passé
donc il y à des adaptations qui sont
faites mais moi c'est simplement je vous
dis que le temps du deuil n'est pas fini
et je n'aime pas du tout cette pouliche
aujourd'hui la justice arrive à suivre
en termes de moyens c'est toujours ceux
qui le disent même s'il ne conteste pas
forcément les mesures qui ont été
décidées
oui la pression en termes de mesure que
ce soit sur l'exécution des peines on a
déjà réduit en fait le problème de
l'inexécution des peines puisque on est
passé de 100 mille peines non exécutées
en janvier à 85 mille aujourd'hui donc
il ya des mesures qui ont été annoncées
sur l'augmentation des places de prisons
sur les mesures pour les mineurs les
centres éducatifs fermés je dirais même
que d'ailleurs même l'opposition sur ces
différentes mesures n'a pas en réalité
vraiment formulé d'opposition mais le
débat politicien tels qu'ils sont
exprimés mais quasiment le jour même
c'était ignoble mais sur ses centres
éducatifs fermés pourquoi ne pas l'avoir
fait avant parce que le gouvernement a
attendu finalement quatre ans le
gouvernement a commencé à alterner
puisque jusqu'à aux annonces
dans une polémique assez forte puisqu'on
nous a opposé qu'on pouvait pas mettre
les jeunes dans des centres éducatifs
fermés il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
beaucoup de polémiques au départ il y
avait pas de vrai consensus sur les
centres éducatifs fermés donc les choses
ont évolué
donc là cela effectivement d'ailleurs le
budget de la justice est le seul budget
parler de l'un des deux seuls qui ne
baisse pas avec celui de la recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur et même qui
augmente on va à passer au mardi vous le
voulez bien avec l ump qui planche sur
son programme économique pour 2012
en ce mardi donc l'ump présente le volet
économique de son projet présidentiel
pour 2012 la convention s'intitule le
rendez vous du courage mais sur le fond
l'ambiance c'est bien plutôt à la
prudence notamment sur l'idée d'une tva
sociale
explications de germes andrieu c'est la
première convention nationale de la
majorité avec à la clé une synthèse des
propositions économiques et sociales
pour 2012 à lambersart à deux pas de
lille la première mesure clip est l'un
des thèmes favoris de l'ump la scène et
35 heures nous allons parler aussi des
35 heures des 35 heures de madame aubry
qui ont été une connerie dont nous nous
remettrons jamais assez pour autant pas
question de changer la durée légale du
temps de travail pour sortir
définitivement des 35 heures la majorité
propose aux partenaires sociaux de
négocier branche par branche
autres propositions clés la refondation
du financement de la protection sociale
pour rendre les entreprises plus
compétitives
la conclusion laquelle nous sommes
arrivés après beaucoup de dialogues
beaucoup de débats entre nous c'est
qu'il fallait mettre en place une
fiscalité anti-délocalisation un
dispositif global qui amène un nouveau
financement de la protection sociale en
france et qui peut reposer sur
différentes sources de financement
à la clé un nouveau bouquet fiscale avec
plusieurs pistes pour financer la
branche famille comme une hausse de la
tva à taux réduit et de la csg contre
une baisse des charges pour les
entreprises mais surtout pas question de
prononcer les mots tabous tva sociale
on n'a jamais parlé tva sociale donc
parler de tva anti délocalisation mais
la formule de fiscalité anti
délocalisation qui était celle proposée
par bruno le maire est infiniment
meilleur parce que elle al'avantage
d'intégrer toutes les formes de
fiscalité ça peut concerner l'impôt sur
les sociétés la tva l'impôt écologique
que défend nathalie au niveau européen
ça peut concerner la csg tout ça c'est à
réfléchir ont lancé éléments dans le
débat il reste donc à définir les
contours et évaluer le coût de
l'ensemble du projet ump
l'objectif reste 0 euros mais une région
de suffrages a déjà été fixée pour le 15
décembre après la troisième et dernière
convention de synthèse alors chantal
jouanno sont les 35 heures on va vous
poser la question tout le monde a posé
cette semaine
si les 35 heures sont si mauvaises que
cela pourquoi ne les at on pas supprimer
plutôt pourquoi est on toujours la
raison était assez simple c'est c'est
pour éviter aux entreprises la double
peine puisque quand elles ont mis en
oeuvre les 35 heures elles ont dû ça
leur a coûté puisque on est passé 39
heures de travail à 35 heures as a l'air
content donc ça leur a coûté et si on
avait dû revenir à 39 heures à l'époque
bien évidemment qu'on n'aurait pas fait
ce même imposera sivement donc dans le
continent mais dans le contexte actuel
honnêtement je ne suis pas sûr que le
contexte soit l'augmentation des charges
pour les entreprises qui aujourd'hui
doivent d'abord créer des emplois donc
c'était possible il s'est à l'époque en
2007 en pré période de crise où la crise
elle a commencé quand même au début de
l'année 2008 les phares les prémices
donc ce n'est pas possible à l'époque de
commencer c'est pour cela qu'il a été
choisi d'alléger le système vial et les
allègements de charges sur les heures
supplémentaires qui aujourd'hui
bénéficier à 9 millions de salariés
l'avantagent de l'allègement des charges
c'est que ça ne pèse pas sur les
entreprises et en même temps ça permet
aux salariés d'avoir du pouvoir d'achat
en plus qu'il ya 9 millions de salariés
qui en bénéficient
chantal jouanno stéphane dor l'agenda
prévisionnel du président sarkozy du
candidat sarkozy en 2006 2007 comme
c'était dans son agenda
il n'y avait pas de consensus sur le
sujet puis alors surtout je vous dit il
à la con le contexte économique était
vraiment pas favorable mais le système
qui a été choisi in fine et je vais
enfin très honnêtement pas se voiler la
face ça on revient quasiment au même en
réalité avec l'allègement de charges sur
les heures supplémentaires
dit non vraiment jean françois copé le
dit on veut supprimer les 35 heures on
revient aussi sur des propositions ont
alors entendu qui était déjà la sonatt
en fait c'est tout ce qui n'a pas été
fait depuis 2007 cette proposition de
l'ump réalisation s'était pas en 2006
savez ça a été évoqué par d'autres après
mais ce n'était pas dans la journal du
président de la république sur le fait d
sur le fait sur les 35 heures d'aller
plus loin et de renvoyer aux partenaires
sociaux
j'allais dire la plus de liberté dans
leurs négociations pourquoi pas à la
limite c'est aux partenaires sociaux
qu'il appartiendra de voir si en
fonction des secteurs
cela peut avoir ça peut avoir un intérêt
sur la question ensuite de la tva
antidélocalisation fin d'année lui liée
au départ de m la tva sociale c'est la
vie c'est pas en fait le vrai débat qui
se pose aujourd'hui on voit bien que
dans notre pays on a un problème on ce
qu'on appelle un problème d'offre c'est
à dire de fragilité de nos de nos
entreprises qui sont pas nécessairement
positionner sur les bons secteurs et qui
surtout ont des charges importantes
il ya tout un débat qui a été ouvert par
le président de la république pour
basculer la fiscalité qui pèse sur le
travail vers d'autres formes de
fiscalité et notamment pour basculer le
poids des charges sociales vers d'autres
formes de fiscalité ça fait pas
consensus puisque historiquement
effectivement ce sont les partenaires
sociaux qui entre guillemets sont les
partenaires des systèmes de protection
sociale donc si on balance ça sur la
sueur de la fiscalité
quelle sera leur place en qu'il ya tout
un débat ouvert avec un quine après
l'été orange l2 oui mais il a justement
renvoyé aux partenaires aux parties dans
le cadre d'un futur au conseil le soin
de réfléchir à cette question du
financement sur la protection sociale et
ça va au delà
moi quand j'avais porté la contribution
carbone c'était bien dans l'idée de dire
il faut au moins deux charges sur le
travail et les faire basculer sur
d'autres sur de la pollution ou sur
d'autres d'autres vecteurs cas mais on a
vu lors de cette convention c'est que le
projet connexe n'est pas du tout boucler
mon côté là on est encore en phase de
réflexion ont enfin accès facile et ceci
dit ce chiffrage c zéro c'est zéro impôt
et c zéro dépense donc ça celui là il
est assez simple il est fait il est tout
de suite fait mais c'est un havre est
bon
débat de s'engager sur des réformes
structurelles et de revoir à fond notre
système de fiscalité je veux dire que
aujourd'hui on peut pas reprendre les
recettes du siècle précédent
l'opposition entre les keynésiens et les
classiques allait terminer ce mandat il
est terminée donc dans le monde qui
s'ouvre poser ce débat de fond se dire
la fiscalité écologique c'est une
fiscalité d'avenir se dire on si on
réduit les charges sociales etc ce qui
permettra d'augmenter les salaires nets
parce qu'on a aussi des salaires nets
beaucoup trop faible en france ça c'est
un bon débat de fond je trouve c'est un
débat sain et il n'a pas à être aussi
autant à ce moment quand même sur l'ump
paris rachida dati
on ne pouvait pas vous en empêcher non
on peux pas m'empêcher parce que
finalement encore une fois cette semaine
il encore été beaucoup de questions d'
attaques de rachida dati xavier bertrand
lui-même dit halte au feu est-ce que
vous aussi vous dites aujourd'hui
halte au feu entre françois fillon
rachida dati mais l'ump jeudi
globalement halte au feu ça suffit de
mettre le feu à l'ump à paris on n'a pas
besoin de ça on est déjà suffisamment
bas on est déjà effectivement
suffisamment discréditer à l'égard des
parisiennes et les parisiens donc stop
qu'on parle un peu de fond qu'est ce que
lui de coarraze et rachida dati
aujourd'hui quand il faut lui donner
comme metz alors déjà 1 je trouve que
cette espèce de l'idée de deals alors
comment est-ce qu'on marchande pour que
tu te tais cétacés c'est pas terrible
comme ça c'est non mais c'est pas
terrible
aux yeux de l'opinion publique donc moi
ce débat-là tous et bizzbee là pour
l'instant effectivement je me suis je
m'en suis jamais mêlé pendant la
campagne des sénatoriales je m'en suis
déjà dans les cénacles arrière ici pas
je n'ai jamais répondu aux attaques le
savoir si jamais je conduis je continue
mon bonhomme de chemin pour faire du
travail de terrain travailler sur un
projet et voilà jacques deray nous
plonger comme dans la bataille pour 2014
à paris je vois la majorité à 2004 dans
le 12e arrondissement alors dans mon
cinéma difficile pour la droite
oui bah oui m'enfin si on va là où c'est
facile c'est pas très drôle
oui enfin moi je commence à ma carrière
politique donc j'ai plutôt à faire mes
preuves c'est pas le cas de françois
fillon
il a déjà et lui c'est plutôt faire
cesser des cadeaux des gens qui viennent
de cette qualité qui viennent à paris
on est devant et rachida dati devrait se
dire quand même que c'est une excellente
chose que des personnes de qualité
vienne vienne à paris quoi donc
et vos mémoires fm arrondissement
combattre des arrondissements plus dix
films dont 17 sélections plus difficile
et je vais pas envie de rentrer dans
cette polémique à deux balles voilà ça
échoue donc je vous répondrai pas donc
moi ça le 12e arrondissement
c'est le projet pour paris demain ça ça
m'intéresse
le reste honnêtement ça m'intéresse bien
vraiment pas du tout c'est pas comme ça
que je vois la politique alors on va
passer à autre chose
ratti toujours les maires de france
réuni en congrès à paris au menu des
débats la crise bien sûr le gouvernement
leur demande de faire des efforts c'est
la grogne des mers reportage fabrice
qu'une et tapis rouge pour les maires et
représentants de collectivités locales
ce salon de la porte de versailles c'est
un vaste marché où l'on signe des
contrats pour tout type d'équipement
mais avec une idée directrice trouver
des économies
aujourd'hui donc on essaye de faire le
moins de dépenses possible du moins
faire les dépenses
plus intelligemment qu'une fois autour
des tables on négocie on fait jouer la
concurrence pour faire baisser les prix
aux exposants de s'adapter
ils cherchent peut-être un peu moins du
gros matériel et cherche peut-être plus
du matériel polyvalent mais surtout au
niveau énergie qui consomment moins qui
fait moins de bruit
leur grande morosité pour l'instant chez
nous
non
officiellement pas de morosité donc des
élus locaux malgré la crise
pas de morosité mais un peu d'agacement
après les récentes réformes
territoriales alors à gauche on n'hésite
pas à dénoncer la politique menée par le
gouvernement
ça fait fort longtemps qu'elle se serre
la ceinture par obligation parce que les
dotations de l'état diminuent et que
l'état étranglant les collectivités
locales ya bien longtemps que les
collectivités locales ont compris qu'il
fallait serrer donc c'est ce qu'elle est
c'est ce qu'elle forme face aux
critiques françois fillon revoit à la
hausse les 3 milliards d'euros dégagés
sur les fonds d'épargné des français
nous sommes prêts avec la caisse des
dépôts et consignations a porté à 5
milliards le niveau de ses fonds pour
faire en sorte que les dépenses de la
fin de l'année et du début de l'année
2012 soit assurée l'enjeu est évidemment
électorale quelques semaines après le
revers aux sénatoriales et avant la
campagne présidentielle
le gouvernement tente de reconquérir son
électorat local un électorat local et on
se souvient lors des élections
sénatoriales jean pierre bel le
président du sénat a promis des états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
tout simplement pour redonner la parole
à ses élus voulaient santé inquiète ses
élus les élus entier je jure ce qu'un
élu qui parle qui sépare un bonus et
structurels chez un élu d'être un style
non mais ceci dit les les élus sont
inquiets pourquoi parce qu'il voit bien
qu'on a une situation de ce qui est
assez compliqué on prend le vélo qu'il y
a et qu'il y a donc aussi des besoins
sociaux qui s'exprime donc les les
maires les maires font effectivement des
efforts depuis longtemps on a quand même
un vrai problème sur la dépense publique
des collectivités territoriales tout
particulièrement dans les départements
et dans l'est dans les régions qu'on
peut pas ignorer
on peut pas ignorer l'état fait des
efforts on fait des efforts aussi sur la
dépense sociale
il est normal que les collectivités
puissent aussi participer à cet effort
mais je mets à part les communes qui
sont elles sûres vraiment des dépenses
ce qu'on appelle les dépenses de
fonctionnement des dépenses sociales qui
sont quasiment des dépenses contraintes
et nicolas sarkozy n'est pas venu au
congrès des maires cette année étaient
venus l'année dernière c'est un peu
dommage écoutez je ne sais absolument
pas pourquoi il a reçu les maires à
l'inversé très dommage que le président
du sénat elle n'est pas souhaité
assister à la réunion qu'a été organisé
à l'elysée à laquelle étaient conviés
qui n'est pas une marque et président du
sénat enfin ces voix là c'est on n'est
pas la cour d'école donc ne s'est pas
très républicain et c'était pas très
républicain ne pas être aux questions
d'actualité non plus ce n'est pas plutôt
au président généralement c'est un peu
la tradition françois fillon s'est
déplacé pour aller pour aller genou
s'écouter genou partenaires à l'agenda
du président de la ligue donc peut-être
que son chef de cabinet pourrait vous
répondre le plus pratique qu'il a il a
reçu les maires effectivement et est
traditionnellement que ce soit majorité
opposition en général l'opposition bien
aussi fayard j'ai jamais vue de
difficultés sa première fois que je vois
sur ce point allez on ce mardi toujours
les propos de yannick noah sur le dopage
arrive dans l'hémicycle lors des
questions au gouvernement à l'assemblée
l'ex champion de tennis a fait sensation
week-end dernier en demandant la
légalisation de la pratique du dopage
dans le sport
votre successeur au ministère des sports
sans surprise n'a pas apprécié on écoute
il s'agit de propos extrêmement graves
et totalement irresponsable
qu'est ce qu'on dit à notre jeunesse est
ce qu'on veut une société qui choisit la
facilité qui bafoue le travail qui
bafoue l'humilité qui bafoue la remise
en question qui bafoue tous que le sport
peut mettre en valeur ou est ce qu'on
choisit ainsi toute une société qui est
responsable qui travaille dans
l'abnégation dans l'humilité et qui se
remet en question chaque jour eh bien ma
vision la société la vision du
gouvernement du premier ministre et du
président de la république
elle est claire nous luttons contre
cette tricherie comme luttons contre
cette vision de la société qui elle
aussi temps à légaliser les drogues qui
ne sont plus douces mais qui sont des
drogues dures voilà ce qu'est ma
position
on suppose que vous auriez répondu de la
même façon a très largement
est ce que quand même à sa façon
provocatrice yannick noah ne
ne dis pas quelques vérités que le
dopage existe toujours dans le sport a
dit louis de boucliers générale
non ya pas une hypocrisie générale le
dopage existe à l'existant bien sûr
qu'il existe et on lutte contre et on
lutte contre dans la continuité depuis
marges du fait que vous allez montrer
sur les images qui a été la première à
s'engager sur ce sur ce sujet alors qu'à
l'époque on lui disait non mais écoutez
il y en a pas ou laisser faire enfin
donc non on lutte contre il ya des
progrès énormes dans la lutte contre le
dopage le tour de france d'aujourd'hui
est dix fois plus contrôlés que ses
prédécesseurs
on est capable de faire des passeports
biologiques pour suivre les sportifs
dans leur parcours depuis le depuis le
départ est de voir justement s'il ya des
progressions tellement fulgurante
qu'elles sont pas du tout du tout
crédible donc c'est faux et surtout
quand il dit que les espagnols nomades
qui ce parce qu'ils sont plus dopé mais
je souhaiterais quand même qu'ils
regardent des résultats de la france
dans d'autres dans d'autres sports que
le tennis qui regardent l'athlétisme qui
regardent la natation qui regardent le
judo qui regardent le karaté et puis ce
pas sympathique à l'égard de son fils
son fils ray quand même ultra
sympathique je fais les choses pas
croire qu'ils se réclament doper l
escapade autres pays qui ont une
politique moins stricte en matière de
dopage
on a nous aimons est très strict ça
c'est vrai et on les strictes dans la
lutte est maintenant dans la dans la
prévention ça c'est vrai mais parce que
le dopage
quand on voit les conséquences
sanitaires que ça peut avoir quand on
voit le message que ça diffuse à l'égard
des jeunes c'est vraiment une c'est
catastrophique donc ça c'est vrai mais
on a aussi une agence mondiale de lutte
contre le dopage qui vais justement à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de pays qui fasse qui
va ce cavalier seul c'est son travail
donc il y a certes il ya des pays qui
auront évidemment qu'il ya des
tentations mais on a aujourd'hui un
système mondial de lutte contre le
dopage est par exemple dans le cyclisme
la généralisation de ce fameux passeport
biologique
ça évitera qu'il y ait des pays qu'ils
fassent entre guillemets cavaliers
cavalier seul mais c'est grave le enfin
vraiment le message que l'on donne est
très grave parce que si on a une
politique des sports c'est qu'on estime
que le sport véhicule des valeurs
vertueuse et dans ses valeurs il ya
notamment la méritocratie dire que si
vous faites des efforts
vous progressez dans le sport c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire le sport ça fait
tomber toutes les barrières sociales
grâce à cela ça a des vertus éducatives
donc à les diffuser ce type de message
surtout avec une personne aussi
médiatique apprécié des français mais
c'est une erreur
c'est une monstrueuse même si je faisais
la provocation c'est une pardon monsieur
même pas de la provocation c'est comment
vous faites du buzz c'est tout et ça je
trouve ça monstrueux on n'a pas le droit
pour son propre buzz de diffuser des
messages pareil à l'égard de nous en
ferons pas ce mercredi la candidate des
écolos fait douter ses propres partisans
eva joly était la bonne candidate
écologiste pour 2012 après une petite
traversée du désert la voici cette
semaine de retour dans les médias
très critique vis-à-vis de l'accord avec
les socialistes à tel point que son
porte-parole claque la porte
récit du nouveau feuilleton au sein de
la famille écologiste c'est signé jeremy
hartmann a depuis son retour médiatique
hier la candidate d'europe écologie
multiplient les attaques
d'abord dans les pages du monde les
socialistes du bois dont on fait les
marionnettes selon elle au 20 heures de
france 2 ensuite eva joly s'en prend à
l'accord signé avec le ps c'est vrai que
cet accord ne me fait pas plaisir et ne
me fait pas rêver
et pour finir ce matin sur rtl la
candidate écologiste refusent de
soutenir clairement françois hollande
pour le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
est-ce que vous appellerez s'il est
qualifié pour le second tour à voter
pour françois hollande qui s'est engagé
à poursuivre la construction de l'epr de
flamanville nous avons toutes les toute
la période des présidentielles de ces
excités de la préparation pour discuter
du nucléaire et moi chez tout ce temps
pour convaincre mes concitoyens que la
voix elle passe à la sortie de ne pouvez
vous répondre et jolie la fermeture des
centrales les flamands de vous répondre
eva joly à ma question et que t'es pas
là non ce par radios interposées les
socialistes riposte est ce que madame
joly est devenue une candidate
indépendante qui vis à vis tout seul ou
est ce que la candidate des verts moi je
pose la question la question
les écologistes cela pose aussi ce matin
yannick jadot va même jusqu'à
démissionner de son poste de
porte parole de la candidate eva joly
tente alors de rectifier le tir
elles appellent finalement à voter
françois hollande dans l'optique d'un
second tour de la présidentielle eva
joly a repris ses propos il les a
rectifié dont acte
cet après midi l'état-major des
écologistes a tenu une réunion d'urgence
pour tirer les enseignements de ces
couacs à répétition une campagne
présidentielle une campagne électorale
d'une manière générale ça nécessite de
la clarté et la maîtrise de la
communication que nous appelons tous de
nos voeux elle passe par des messages
clairs sans ambiguïté direct je crois
qu'elle sera plus entourées et keira
meilleure coordination entre le parti et
la candidature demain eva joly retourne
sur le terrain
en déplacement en bourgogne la candidate
sera très attendu sur la clarté de son
message politique tout un joyau vous
regardiez le sujet qu'un petit sourire
c'est du pain béni pour la majorité
cette affaire il nous appartient pas à
nous de choisir entre les différents
candidats des verts c'est ça c'est leur
affaire
c'est vrai qu'en cet accord je suis
normand donc je peux le dire j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était un peu
peut-être ben qu'oui ptêt ben qu'non
donc c'est pas non plus un accord
effectivement très très clair mais c'est
surtout grave sur le fond parce que
enfin moi j'ai toujours été très
convaincu pas à l'écologie ça m'a valu
quelques déboires donc mais je trouve
que résumer l'écologie à être
systématiquement antinucléaires sans
dire toute la vérité sur ce que
comporterait même une réduction de 50%
du nucléaire c'est c'est malhonnête et
pour moi l'écologie ça ne se résume pas
à ça et attend débat sur le maire
honnêtement il y a qu'en france qu'on
voit de tels débats aussi réducteur sur
les questions d'écologie parce que ça va
l'allemagne est loin des mesures plus
radicales contre le nucléaire
l'allemagne elle n'est pas dans la même
situation que la france sur le nucléaire
puisqu'il n'avait dans leur mix
énergétique électrique que 25% du clair
quand on est à 78 %
pour eux le coût est estimé moi je
prends les chiffres tels qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui donnée par les experts à 250
milliards donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
a les moyens de le faire est ce que est
ce que le fait de réduire le nucléaire
suppose de compenser trouver d'autres
formes de nuit
on sait que si on développe au maximum
les énergies renouvelables on ne sera
qu'à 23 % de notre mix énergétique en
2020 donc ça suppose de recourir au
charbon ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'allemagne en émissions de gaz à effet
de serre par habitant est très au dessus
de très au dessus de la de la france ou
alors ont réduit fortement notre
consommation d'énergie et là on tombe
dans la décroissance c'est le discours
des verts mais il faut il le disent pas
jusqu'au bout ils le disent dans
l'hémicycle ça oui mais pour le rire
pierre jusqu'au poser une petite
question de ça c'est pour eva joly
mais il ya une autre personne qui s'est
portée candidate c'est françois bayrou
et alain juppé a dit aujourd'hui
en somme un autre candidat mais si on
est candidat françois bayrou candidat
alain juppé appelle n'a pas commettre
l'irréparable face à françois bayrou et
à ne pas en gros insulter l'avenir vous
dis la même chose aujourd'hui mais
françois barrault bayrou est dans la
continuité il a été effectivement à
chaque fois candidat dans différentes
il a il a dit qu'il allait être candidat
alors aux différents télévision aux
différentes élections présidentielles
une porte
il porte une parole et je crois que dans
toutes ces élections présidentielles le
drame que l'on a c'est toujours de
s'invectiver effectivement de faire
tourner les débats sur des questions de
personnes
c'est toutes ces candidatures sont
intéressantes si on arrive à vraiment
distinguer ce qui distingue ce qui
clivent entre une telle ou telle
personne sert quels sont leurs idées de
fond qui font qu'ils expliquent leur
propre leur propre survie n'est pas
forcément un candidat facile pour les
socialistes mais françois bayrou à sa
façon n'est pas forcément non plus un
candidat facile pour l'ump au mais nous
on n'est pas dans des marchandages de 25
réacteurs versus 25 circonscriptions
donc on a en a pas on n'a pas de deal
comme ça avec françois letourneux on
respecte sa candidature on mais on n'est
pas là d'ores et déjà à dire à dire on
fait systématiquement un deal fins et on
n'est pas du tout dans cette logique là
on a l'habitude j'allais dire à droite
d'avoir des candidats comme comme
françois bayroux donc pour nous on est
pas on n'est pas dans la même logique
fois et puis franchement c'est quelqu'un
de mon cou respectant il a il avait un
parcours politique exemplaire
on va s'intéresser au sénat mercredi la
majorité socialiste sénat s'attaque au
budget présenté par le gouvernement ou
une fois de plus c'est un texte
complètement remaniée qui a été voté les
sénateurs de gauche veulent ainsi
montrer des styles qu'en pleine crise
d'autres choix sont possibles le détail
du vote
elisa bartoloni c'est un véritable
détricotage du plf que la gauche
sénatoriale a opéré elle s'est attaquée
aux mesures phares mises en place durant
le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
en premier lieu la loi tepa symbole du
travailler plus pour gagner plus du
président de la république
les sénateurs socialistes ont fait voter
deux amendements d'envergure
l'abrogation des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées
mais surtout la suppression immédiate
bouclier fiscal initialement prévue en
2013 ils ont aussi créer une tranche
d'impôt supplémentaire de 46% pour les
revenus supérieurs à 100 mille euros et
voté la pérennisation de la contribution
sur les hauts revenus
l'impôt sur les sociétés a été réformé
conséquence les grandes entreprises
seront plus taxés à droite on condamne
le jeu auquel s'est adonné la majorité
sénatoriale
la gauche a voulu faire une
démonstration démonstration de sa
majorité en même temps démonstration en
matière de politique fiscale
autre sujet abordé par la gauche
sénatoriale la contribution des
collectivités locales le sénat a dit non
à l'effort de rigueur de 200 millions
d'euros demandés aux collectivités
enfin la taxe sur les boissons sucrées
les sodas mesure du premier plan de
rigueur de françois fillon a été
supprimé le ps a estimé que cette taxe
ne serait pas dans le plan national
nutrition santé
alors le détricotage c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure un peu en début
d'émission c'est ce sénat nouveau
laboratoire du prochain candidat
socialiste cc oui c'était un exemple
c'est vrai que c'est un peu dommage par
rapport à l'engagement que tu es celui
du président du sénat de ne pas en faire
la chambre d'écho de solférino ou du
candidat socialiste donc de grenier de
faire la proposition est pour l'heure
c'est pour nous opposition ja lire que
l'intérêt c'est que la campagne
présidentielle commence ici ceci dit en
termes de mesures vous évoquez la loi de
finances on peut évoquer aussi le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
et quand on combine quand on combine les
deux effectivement la logique en fait ce
qui distingue dodo logique on essaie de
faire des efforts sur les dépenses c'est
grosso modo 50% du plf et 25% du plfss
et de modérer les hausses d'impôts ils
sont pas du tout dans cette logique
c'est on compense le déficit budgétaire
uniquement par par la hausse d'impôts
donc résultat des courses
effectivement on supprime la
défiscalisation sur les heures
supplémentaires 9 millions de salariés
qui seront concernés par cette par cette
mesure ont rétabli les droits de
succession vous n'avez pas cité mais ont
rétabli les droits de succession sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés de vision
or une messe pour chanter ça touche
aussi les pme ce qu'ils ont visé donc on
est on est très clairement sur une
logique qui revient toujours et
systématiquement sur de toute façon il
faut faire du partage du temps de
travail ou de l'emploi public et c'est
pas du tout ma logique je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les autres sociétés qui
sait de la société qui s'affrontent au
sénat je pense que ses recettes quand
était celle d'une part de 80 et ensuite
et ensuite du demanda de lionel jospin
n'ont pas marché
le résultat de ce que c'est de cette
politique c'est un endettement qui a été
multiplié par 21 depuis 1981 et c'est ce
qui crée la crise d'endettement actuels
donc on ne peut pas reprendre
systématiquement les mêmes mesures et
revenir systématiquement effectivement
sur d'anciennes politique rappelle que
sont les députés qui ont le dernier mot
dans cette affaire que donne toutes ces
mesures ne seront pas appliquées pour le
prochain budget bien sûr et devant les
3000 maires réunis à l'elysée on en
parlait tout à l'heure nicolas sarkozy
ce mercredi se dit contre le vote des
étrangers hors union européenne pour les
élections municipales
il réagit à une proposition de loi
socialiste qui sera présenté au sénat le
8 décembre prochain
proposition hasardeuse selon lui on
écoute une telle proposition me semble
hasardeuse parce qu'elle présente je
dois terminer je voudrais
parce que c'est un sujet extrêmement
important
elle me semble hasardeuse
parce que cette proposition risque de
diviser profondément les français au
moment où plus que jamais nous avons
besoin de les rassembler chacun peut
avoir ses convictions et de ce point de
vue n'y a aucun délit dit est
naturellement
alors retour en arrière en 2005 le même
nicolas sarkozy disait un étranger en
situation régulière qui travaillent qui
paient des impôts et réside depuis au
moins 10 ans france il ne serait pas
anormal qu'ils votent chantal jouanno
laquelle des deux déclarations
préférez-vous et sous conditions de
réciprocités vous avez oublié aussi
cette dernière condition qu'ils avaient
qu'il avait posée ce que ce que dit le
président de la république c'est que la
proposition de loi dont on va discuter
il faut préciser les seins sans
condition de ressources sans conditions
de réciprocités sans condition non plus
de maîtrise de la langue d'un vote
éclairé suppose au moins une maîtrise de
la langue
cette proposition de loi et dans le
contexte actuel est ce que vous croyez
vraiment qu'on peut en débattre de
manière apaisée dans le contexte actuel
dans le contexte pré électoral onpe en
débatte 2 donc ça c'est déjà sur la
forme c'est clairement dans un coup
politique que ce débat est engagé
et si les deuxièmes était rempli sa
deuxième relais sur les conditions à
remplir en france depuis 1795 on a
toujours lié le droit de vote à la
nationalité et on a une nationalité
contrairement aux autres pays d'ailleurs
qui ont ouvert le droit de vote aux
étrangers dans lesquelles il est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir la
nationalité on a une nationalité
aujourd'hui qui est pas fondée sur le
droit du sang mais sur le droit du sol
donc on peut acquérir par relativement
facilement mais en tout cas on n'est pas
des années et des années à l'acquérir
et c'est vrai que je passais volontiers
ce que lisent et maso sur ce sujet il
n'y a pas on peut pas faire une sous
citoyenneté ou une citoyenneté au rabais
pour une partie de notre notre
population que ça c'est vraiment de
vision de fond qui s'opposent mais
vraiment je trouve que le débat qui est
posée comme vous êtes
ehpad à ce que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
à ce que disait nicolas sarkozy en 2005
2007 et line on met alors à l'époque il
était il était enfin ils disaient qu'ils
s'interrogeaient qui se posaient la
question qui n'était pas outrageusement
scandalisé par la proposition
voilà comment il le définissait mais
honnêtement c'est poser ce débat sans
s'interroger sur les conditions
d'obtention de la nationalité sur la
question de la maîtrise de la langue
quand on vote mais en y mettant les gens
de l'histoire y est simple qu'ils
rencontrent sur le principe
sur le principe on n'est pas forcément
compte dès lors que les gens ont envie
de participer à la vie publique
alors est-ce qu'on fait sous la forme
d'un droit de vote aux élections locales
est-ce qu'on fait comme les allemands
mais eux ils ont une nationalité fondée
sur le droit du en partie fondée sur le
droit du sang sous la forme de débats
locaux dans des dents des dents des
conférences local municipal les
modalités peuvent être peuvent être
discutés mais vraiment compter sur moi
et 2012 moi je n'aime pas cette espèce
de dix paires politisation du débat sur
le droit de vote des étrangers
c'est vraiment on fait de la politique
ah voilà donc avant l'amérique alors
chantal jouanno je dirige et aux pierres
belle annonce une série de mesures pour
un nouveau sénat
à l'instar de l'assemblée nationale le
sénat verra son budget réduit de 3% dans
le contexte actuel le nouveau président
du sénat veut à senna exemplaire des
économies plus de transparence le détail
des annonces signé alexandra colinot ce
sont des histoires de chiffres qui ne
passionne pas le nouveau président du
sénat je suis un ici en tant que
responsable politique je suis pas arrivé
ici pour être le super intendant du
sénat qui doit se préoccuper de la cave
du grenier se demande s il faut pas
repeindre la façade c'est pas tout de
même l'essentiel de mes préoccupations
pas l'essentiel mais l'une des premières
annonces depuis son élection le budget
du sénat de près de 330 millions d'euros
sera réduit de 3%
concrètement les frais de déplacement
des sénateurs notamment dans le cadre de
groupes d'amitiés seront diminuées de
20%
certains travaux seront gelés du côté
des dépenses outre la création du
nouveau groupe parlementaire des verts
et il faudra financer une nouvelle
commission permanente sur le
développement durable chiffré à 280
milles euros par jean pierre bel
elle fait grincer les dents de la
nouvelle opposition à mon avis c'est une
des ponts signifie surtout
d'opportunités pour donner des postes
certains qui on réclame jean pierre bel
v aussi un sénat transparent le budget
sera désormais débattue en séance
plénière
l' ordonnance de 1958 ne permet pas une
telle disposition mais qu importe les
modalités je sais que
constitutionnellement un effet il faut
revoir cette ordonnance
de quelle manière un footix y prendre je
consulterai ceux qui ont une une science
beaucoup plus jusqu'à la gueule
dernier point évoqué ce matin la réserve
parlementaire le président du sénat a
estimé qu'elles devaient être répartis à
la proportionnelle des groupes
même s'il s'en débarrasserait volontiers
de groupes de travail sont chargés
d'étudier ces questions de dépenses et
de transparence
le premier bilan sera rendu à la fin de
l'année sa veuve économies autant le
crif est plutôt une bonne nouvelle ce
qu'annonce heures ici je me permets les
plus de transparence au cifa va dans le
bon sens
enfin ça va dans le sens de l'histoire
d'ailleurs gérard larcher a donc déjà
engagé cette mesure sera clos
sur les économies du sénat en fait on
n'est qu'à 3 % de baisse du budget donc
ça va il n'y a pas ça la réserve
parlementaire sur l'autre sur la sur la
transparence
oui c'est le sens de l'histoire et
l'éthique en politique je pense qu'on
est on devra aller de toute façon
beaucoup plus loin moi j'ai tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'on vaut déclaration
que ce soit de patrimoine ou de où le
conflit d'intérêts soit totalement
transparente et il n'y a pas de débat là
dessus je suis partie d'une génération
qui ne voit pas le problème sur ces sur
ces sujets là ensuite après sur les
décisions de fond la grande halle il ya
de grandes décisions et à la création du
groupe à 10 et puis d'autre part la
question de la création d'une commission
de développement durable sur ce deuxième
point le premier cd arrangement entre ça
c'est leur force de pousser leurs
problèmes le deuxième c'est un vrai
sujet de fond c'est un débat c'est parce
qu'on avait pris cet engagement dans le
cadre du grenelle pour l'assemblée
nationale d'avoir une commission
développement durable qui soit une
commission spécifique à l'époque moi je
pensais que c'était plutôt une bonne
idée d'ailleurs maintenant mais en tant
que ministre je me suis rendu compte
qu'on doublonner systématiquement le
travail parce que par exemple les
questions d'énergie vous les mettez ou
en général et j'adore la commission des
affaires économiques
vous pouvez pas parler d'écologie sans
parler d'énergie donc vous êtes obligé
de vous présenter devant les deux
commissions et de débattre du texte
devant les deux commissions
systématiquement donc vous oxygéner aux
ministres aux sharks de san jose pas lui
et ça gêne même de toute façon les
rapporteurs et le travail et l'examen de
la et l'examen de la loi mais surtout je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui sur les questions
d'écologie faut avoir une vision
transversale
et quand on parle le véritable enjeu de
l'écologie aujourd'hui ces questions
d'urbanisme c'est les questions de
logement c'est les questions de
transport ces questions de consommation
et donc c'est mieux d'avoir de lier
l'ensemble
ma mission est de ne pas les séparer moi
j'ai choisi de siéger à l'ordre ils vont
pas prendre des personnes dans d'autres
commissions a priori moi je suis j'ai
choisi de siéger dans les affaires
sociales parce que je pense que la
deuxième étape de la réflexion sur
l'écologie c'est la question de la
solidarité etc les questions de société
allez on va terminer la semaine avec la
disparition de danielle mitterrand
femmes militantes femme engagée femme de
président atypique
farouchement attaché à son indépendance
qui disait profité de son statut de
première dame de france pour faire
avancer ces combats pas toujours
conformes à la diplomatie du moment elle
s'est éteinte à l'âge de 87 ans elle ne
laissait pas indifférent elle provoqué
l'admiration ou l'agacement vous même
chantal jouanno comment la perceviez
vous bas et j'ai gelé connu puisque on a
travaillé on a échangé sur la question
de l'eau et du droit et du droit à l'eau
est effectivement c'était un combat
alors on n'avait pas sur les modalités
on n'avait pas exactement la même la
même vision mais je veux pas rentrer
dans le détail mais ont partagé cette
idée qu'il était totalement anormal que
les nations unies et notamment dans le
cadre des objectifs du millénaire pour
le développement ne place pas la
question de l'eau et de l'accès à l'eau
en tête de ses priorités parce que c'est
la première cause de mortalité dans le
monde loin devant les guerres ou ou les
maladies le sida en l'occurrence c'est
c'est la première raison qui fait que
vous souffrez aujourd'hui de problèmes
de développement de famille vous prenez
une grande association comme action
contre la faim
cinquante pour cent de ses actions c'est
la lutte contre la dénutrition 50% c'est
l'axé et 1,6 me jusqu'au bout vous
voulez de mériller je fais une femme
assez d'une femme
lure dur mais libre et je trouve que
c'est le militantisme et l'engagement
aujourd'hui quelles que soient les les
couleurs politiques le respecte et je l
admire est ce que j'admire pas du tout
c'est les faiseurs de politique mais
j'admire beaucoup l'engagement d'accord
très bien passé beaucoup chantal jouanno
bien sûr ces mots on va se quitter se
retrouver
la semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
émissions même jour même heure
merci au revoir